let's go back to our top story the legal
hunting of an elephant in Namibia let's
meet a masculine Nina an international
trade policy specialists at the Wildlife
Department of the Humane Society
International in Johannesburg am
thanks very much home for speaking to us
this morning and what do you make of
Namibia's method of tackling elephant
conservation allowing legal hunting well
first of all thank you so much for
having a Humane Society International on
your show and our organization opposes
all forms of trophy hunting we're
killing animals for fun now I want to
make something clear about in the minute
bein Namibia is a very special case in
Africa it has one of the lowest levels
of corruption according to Transparency
International and one of the lowest
levels of human population for its
geographic size this is not something
that's replicated in any other country
in southern Africa where trophy hunting
is practiced so this set of
circumstances is really what allows for
good conservation outcomes and it's
really not trophy hunting that is
responsible for some of the successes in
Namibia so I think that first and
foremost we believe that trophy hunting
is not necessary for it Namibia to be
successful at conserving its animals and
that photo tourism would actually be
much more successful well what
professional hunters are arguing is that
it it by keeping F and hunting legal
people people they can see the benefit
of popo ting in terms of that the money
it brings the economy the jobs it's
bringing to people in the area who
otherwise would it wouldn't have jobs if
not for this well that's the interesting
part is that when you compare
photographic tourism and trophy hunting
a photographic tourism operates
year-round trophy hunting about six
months a year one camp may see about 30
hunters versus a photographic camp can
bring in over two thousand people now
you do the math which camp requires more
staff and employs more people so if we
want to benefit local communities
let's employ people through photographic
tourism well has it really worked though
because we have been doing that for
years and now these elephants are are
nearly extinct has it been successful
well I mean generally with tourism as a
whole as then it's the saving grace for
for the South African countries and I'll
give you an example we've recently
commissioned an economic study and I can
show you a chart here this is tourism
employment for eight countries that we
assessed in Africa and all tourism
brings in over two million jobs and this
is trophy hunting down here and then we
are looking at tourist spending over
14.5 billion dollars is spent from all
tourism
this is trophy hunting down here so if
if you're saying that tourism isn't
working while men trophy hunting is
certainly at the bottom as well
well mush we we couldn't really see see
that diagram that you did that he had
there but have you actually had a chance
to watch this this VT by our special
correspondent Alex Crawford have you
seen it yes and I'd be happy to comment
on the video well when you from what you
saw in it the professional hunter when
he killed the elephant he was brought to
tears you mentioned that this is being
done for fun this is this is a man who
is actually trying to save elephants he
says he wants his his daughter to see
elephants while in wildlife rather than
seeing them in the zoo this is something
that he genuinely believes in the long
term will save the number of elephants
in his country well a few things about
the video number one it took seven shots
to kill that elephant and over four
hours until it was finally dead and
interestingly enough I watched as the
safari operator guided your cameras away
from the convulsing body of the elephant
as it was laying there dying because
this is graphic and you wouldn't have
needed that graphic warning at the
beginning of the video because was not
disturbing for people to watch so I
think that even his daughter would find
images like this disturbing and seeing
him brought to tears well if I watch the
majestic elephant died before my eyes an
animal that actually mourns the dead and
I guarantee you that his herd will mourn
that elephant and not even to mention
that he was probably breeding bull and
is important biologically to that herd
I would be brought to tears as well I
mean actually this is this is really
something I think we can go back and
forth through here in terms of the best
way to to deal with elephant
conservation in Africa and Namibia but
from your point of view from your
perspective what is the best way to deal
with it because there's been a number of
methods been introduced to try and
increase numbers to prevent and these
these animals from becoming extinct not
necessarily all of them have worked what
do you think needs to be done I think we
need to put an end to making commodities
out of our wildlife and putting a price
on their head this is what has created
the poaching crisis of the African
elephant that we see today is the
incredible value glaced monetary value
placed on their tasks and what we are
messages only elephants need their tusks
and we did not need them so we need to
stop treating them as commodities and
depreciate them in the wild
through photographic tourism which
brings in billions of dollars into the
economies of South African countries
okay mark hello Nina from the Wildlife
Department of the Humane Society
International thanks so much indeed